[Music]
[Laughter]
tell me one thing
do you feel sad
or maybe lonely
or depressed
anxious
tired burned out
full of dread or despair
maybe you feel alienated from other
people
like you're apart or adrift
if so you are not alone everyone
practically everyone is feeling the same
way
they are the dominant feelings of our
time
you've probably heard this described as
a
mental health crisis and that's true
something has gone wrong with our heads
with our mental health
something is out of whack
just take a look at the world around us
we live in an age of overwhelming
atomization
more and more people report that they
feel deeply lonely
americans especially young americans
report having fewer friends and fewer
romantic partners or meaningful
connections than dead people of past
generations perhaps not coincidentally
rates of depression and anxiety
and if behaviors associated with them
are going up
way up
more people than ever are using
antidepressant medications like ssris
and
more and more people are committing
suicide
or considering it
in june 2020
a quarter of young americans seriously
considered committing suicide
suicides
and drug overdoses
classified as deaths of despair
have become so common that they have
driven down american life expectancy
from its peak in 2014.
by 2021
fentanyl overdose was the most common
form of death
among americans aged 18 to 45.
all around us
we detect a mood of pessimism
nihilism
self-destruction
fewer people having children
more people killing themselves
more and more people dying from
overdoses
more and more people becoming dependent
on pharmaceuticals
talk to young people or students or
really anyone and it's hard to deny this
simple truth
something is very
wrong
[Music]
but the response to this quote unquote
mental health crisis is a very telling
one
our major institutions from schools
colleges workplaces how do they respond
they say that it's something as simple
as better work life balance they might
encourage you to take regular
five-minute breaks from work
or give you zeloft maybe suggest you up
your prescription
they might suggest you push a
notification on your phone to let you
know if you spent too much time staring
at your screen
they do everything except the one thing
which is to solve the essential problem
the real problem is that the system
itself will keep you complacent and
productive enough for its purposes but
the real problem the depression the
anxiety the loneliness
that does not go away
because we're treating this as an
individual problem and not a social
problem
they turn a social problem
a political problem
into a biological one
and while that might make sense on an
individual level it does not make sense
from the perspective of a society
because it is not normal for so many
people to be this depressed
it is not normal for so many people
especially young people to be so reliant
on antidepressants
it is not normal for them to feel so
alone
for them to kill themselves at such high
rates for them to report such high rates
of anxiety and loneliness and depression
that is not normal
there is something really wrong
mental illness depression anxiety these
may manifest neurologically
but they are socially and spiritually
rooted if so many people in a society
are depressed
if so many people are killing themselves
if so many people are reliant on pills
just trying to avoid suicide
that says
something something bad
about the society in question
we are the loneliest people in human
history
there has never been a society as
atomized as alienated
as alone as we are now
it is unprecedented in the hundreds of
thousands of years that humans have been
on earth for us to be this separated
from each other
because the truth is
that at a basic level
we are hardwired for connection
we need other people
we find ourselves our identities
our meaning and our purpose through
other people
we are social animals
we have an urge to love
and to be loved
to be recognized
to be respected and to belong
we need other people
we need family
we need friends
we need a community
and we live in a society now where for
far too many people
those things are impossible
let's begin with a man named robert
putnam
a few decades ago putnam was a famous
professor a sociologist who studied the
trends and changes in american life
and in the 1990s putnam was taking a
look at what had shifted in america
since the 1960s
and as he looked putnam began to find
something disturbing
american community was falling apart
if you look back at american history you
find something kind of incredible
[Music]
the level of organic community in the
united states
from its founding to just a few decades
ago was remarkably strong
go back a hundred years and look at the
communities around you
towns and cities on america used to be
places with vibrant and thriving
communal life
they had labor unions
charity associations gardening clubs
bridge clubs
churches scout troops
people went to local parades they knew
their neighbors they knew what was going
on in their community
and that sense of community is what gave
meaning to their lives
it's how they met their friends their
spouses it's where they raised their
kids
it's what filled out the contours of
their lives it's what made them happy
you could be an ordinary person living
an ordinary life and you could find
dignity and community
a sense of worth in these places
you had a social world all around you
you had a net of support all around you
but by the 1990s as putnam was looking
at the country around him he found a
social world in decay
because starting in the 1960s and
accelerating ever since then
all these communities and institutions
had been collapsing
[Music]
church attendance was falling local
clubs were closing down
local newspapers were losing readers
unions were losing members
families were falling apart
community was disintegrating
americans were withdrawing
going inward
they stopped even knowing who their
neighbors were
they stopped going to parades or civic
events
they stopped being a part of any real
local community at all
even things as simple as local bowling
leagues were disappearing
putnam wrote that americans had begun in
his words
bowling alone
americans were now spending more and
more time without other people
they were expressing lower and lower
levels of social trust
not just in their leaders
but in each other
the social fabric of american life was
unraveling
and once you understand that basic fact
the decline of organic communities
the last few decades of american life
start to make a lot of sense
because without organic communities
around them
people were deprived of the support and
comfort and stability that they had once
enjoyed not to mention friendship
and love
they regarded each other with more
suspicion
life became zero sum
everyone was in it for themselves
and when everyone around you was a
stranger
just becomes about you
about getting what's yours
about becoming a ceo or a billionaire
getting out on top and screwing over
everyone else if necessary
all of life
has been consumed by the logic of the
market
everything becomes a marketplace
everything can be bought or sold
working earning competing consuming that
becomes the sum total of life
money becomes more important than life
itself
and what did people get for this
life didn't get better it got worse you
work longer hours for lower wages
you paid more than your parents or your
grandparents did to go to school or to
see a doctor
owning your own home raising children
these became a lot more difficult it got
harder just to keep your head above
water
and you'd have to do it without the
support that your parents or your
grandparents had enjoyed
fewer friends fewer relationships less
community
life became colder
and emptier
and more unforgiving
more people living without human
companionship and even the most
successful people were unhappy they
reported high rates of depression of
anxiety even they were frustrated and
lonely
and young people just coming into the
world
they have been the worst off
without organic communities everyone
becomes the same
identity
becomes a matter of consumer preference
in the age of the internet atomized
people drift into alternate realities
where they can be anyone but themselves
cults
extremism scams
amid the vast meaninglessness of a
society in decay
some just forged new identities
at first it was just young people
and then it was everyone else
we spent more time with electronics than
we did with humans
our identities were shaped by algorithms
written by corporations in order to make
us buy stuff we don't need
social media designed to make you feel
angry and alone but also to addict you
that became the core of our social
existence
asmr videos that simulate intimacy
internet porn addiction that makes real
romance almost impossible
video streams of people playing video
games and talking these are all
substitutes for the human companionship
that is lacking everywhere else in our
society
it only accelerated the atomization
the loneliness
the depression
older people once treated as sources of
guidance and wisdom
began to be viewed as useless wastes of
space
shuffled into nursing homes high rates
of elder loneliness
has led to elder abuse and high rates of
elder suicide
that is the world that we created
cold
and empty
it's no wonder why people become
dependent on antidepressant drugs
why more people die from overdoses
why more express a desire to kill
themselves
to not exist at all
these are what you call morbid symptoms
they are reflections of a society in
which the market has taken over all of
life
in which human community and human
values have all but disappeared
traditional forms of community and
solidarity that have given meaning to
human life
have been dismantled
life has become about lines on a graph
going up and down
human community has not only been
neglected but actively destroyed
all of human life
has undergone an impoverishment
we live in a society that is
structurally unable to meet our social
needs
the need for community
for love
for being with other people
it is a society that whittles our
humanity down to statistics
stock market lines tick up
so do death tolls the abstraction of
money
has become more real than our actual
lives
we've become a society without meaning
a society that wants you to be
constantly working constantly consuming
it doesn't necessarily want you to talk
to other people it doesn't want you to
be part of a community it doesn't want
you to find meaning outside the market
a society that wants you to be an
atomized consumer
so that it can manipulate you it wants
you to be an atomized worker so that it
can exploit you
[Music]
the reason you feel this way is because
you want to live a real life
you want to be with other people
to join hands with them
to work in meaningful pursuits
to recognize them as friend as partner
a child
a person
and no matter how materially satisfying
any society is
we are yearning for something
something that can exist
that should exist
but that our current system cannot allow
to exist
we are yearning for community
we are yearning for other people
for connection
for friendship
we are yearning for a world where those
things can exist
and that world can exist
in small glimpses
in small moments
it actually already does
it is a world that is struggling to be
born
there is nothing impossible about that
world
because the ultimate truth about it is
that it is something we can imagine we
can create
a more beautiful world
a more wonderful world
a more human world
i'm maryam williamson
for the gravelands
you